What I like about this,
you see the fact that the,
the,
the culture of the patriarchy,
God,
the father will say here is,
is holding the suffering individual in
his arms and that's encapsulated by
nature.
It's,
it's very much like the story in
Pinocchio where Japan Know Pinocchio
wasn't able to go down into the depths
to confront the terrible monster at the
bottom of being without having support
from his father.
Even though his father ended up trapped
inside the whale.
If he wouldn't have been supported to
begin with,
he wouldn't have been able to do it.
And you know,
I've really seen this.
I've really seen this in people.
It's a hell of a thing not to have the
confidence of your father.
It's really,
really hard on people.
You know,
if your father is someone who says to
you,
you can do it,
I really believe that you can do it.
I'll support you in what you're doing.
I think that you can sort it out and
then acts towards you in that way.
That's a gift that really almost no one
else can provide you with mothers
obviously provide.
I think they provide the same kind of
gift,
but earlier,
you know,
because the mother has to take care of
the infant when the infant is just
completely dependent and so,
and this is Erickson's idea to Eric
Erickson is the mother is,
is the person who establishes the
relationship that allows the developing
person to manifest trust,
real truck while you're being carried
for crying out loud,
you know you can be dropped and the
mother is also the source of food,
but the father seems to be something
like the and I'm being.
I'm obviously parsing these things
farther apart than they can be need to
be because the father can play a
nurturing role in the mother
complaining,
encouraging role,
but we'll,
we'll keep it simple for now.
The father seems to be the thing that
supports and encourages and says,
well,
yeah,
you know,
you're little and small and all of that
and you're subject to destruction and
and,
and bullying and social pressure and all
that.
But I know you can do it.
I know you can do it and there's a force
in that that's unbelievable.
And people who don't have that half a
have a hell of a time.
It's actually one of the things that's
quite fun about doing psychotherapy
because you get people who have damaged
father figures.
It's harder with a damaged mother figure
a because it's so bloody deep.
You know?
I had a client who I just,
I just thought she was a remarkable
person,
but her relationship with her mother was
really disrupted.
It was really,
really hard to.
She said she would.
She.
She told me it was like something had
been torn out of her at an early age
that couldn't be replaced.
It's ray because you just can't be
someone's mother,
you know,
it's really hard.
You're just not there enough for that.
But you can sort of be someone surrogate
father that's a,
that's a role you can play later.
And that's what educators do at least to
some degree,
although now they're trying to be
mothers and providing safe spaces and
all of that,
which is not really all that
appropriate.
So that.
So the father is an encouraging figure
and allows the individual,
at least in principle,
to support the catastrophe of being
voluntarily and so anyways,
so those,
you know,
those images,
they're just be a brilliant beyond
belief.
Absolutely brilliant.
Beyond belief.